derek scuba already making his sixth
start here at the major league level his
first career appearance against kansas
city obviously had a and monday will be
on with one out and here's salvador
perez and it doesn't matter how long his
layoff is when he comes back it's like
he hasn't missed a day
salvi turns on it and hits it into the
corner and gone number six for salvi and
he just
keeps on hitting since coming back and
the royals lead two nothing oh man
dusabi was sitting on a fastball he got
one where he liked it and now brady
singer in his first start since his
near-no-hitter victor reyes who was not
part
of the tigers offense last night
he was
over five
with a couple of line outs last night
and a fastball and brady begins the
night with a three-pitch strikeout
willy castro
so a strikeout and a lost bat i don't
know if you can have a worse plate
appearance than willie castro just had
so two down and here's miguel cabrera
here's the pitch fastball in their
strike three call that young man threw
10 pitches in the inning all of them
strikes and he strikes out the side
targets will fully shift on bubba
starling again a righty loaded lineup
and he takes care of starling as well
and the royals in a one two three second
singer is very demanding athlete he's
been pretty good to start this one with
four straight strikeouts the o2 pitch
swung on and missed struck him out that
is five strikeouts his career high tied
it in that last start
haas
who's a local kid
out over the plate and monday makes a
nice play
and a throw on a bounce and dozier
stayed with it for the out oh man
both ends of it
takes a lot of range and haas in his
first at-bat of the year this year in
the big leagues
gets robbed and now sergio alcantara
and he rings him up as well another 11
pitch inning for brady singer nine up
nine down that includes six strikeouts
for the rookie out of florida one up one
down will castrate
this one lifted to the left it's back
drop
castro's hustling and he puts on the
brakes
he made him make it made him throw it
anyway that extends willy castro's home
hitting streak to six games now
have been first and second two down for
the home club good room weights
singer
reaches up
hands and that's the inning brady singer
handles out number three
with his glove
couple of hits couple men left we go to
the fifth is we'll have it royals lead
it two nothing lopez the only lefty in
the lineup tonight that's a career-high
strikeout for tarik skubal give him
seven on the night
and he's through four and a half jorge
bonifacio
was the first tiger to put the ball in
play against singer tonight
and that is strikeout
number seven tonight so both pitchers
tonight have struck out seven in five
innings whitmerfield leads off the
royals
it's short so is that hit and pass
castro that'll be a base hit
he's running
and the throw comes in on a bounce and
that is stolen base number nine
and a runner at second with one out
salvi
drives it to the gap in right center
field and this time the tigers will not
run that one down
[Applause]
so salvi has a double he has an rbi and
the royals take a three-nothing lead in
the sixth inning and now salvador perez
is hitting over 500 since coming back
from the injured list oh come on zombie
you're making it look easy big runner to
stranded third
scubas 90th pitch strikes out hunter
dozier
a career high eight punch out seven
strikeouts 62 pitches in five innings
back from 3-0 and brady singer gets his
eighth strikeout and the second time
he's gotten reyes
perez
walks to load the bases and there here
is franco
that's going to skip away from haas and
here comes whit down from third so the
royals to this point
don't need a big hit with the bases
loaded they'll take a wild pitch and
it's four nothing in the eighth inning
two men aboard for whitmer field here's
the payoff with runners in motion ripped
to third nice play by alcantara
long throw
and boy nice job by candelario they get
mirrorfield
two outs in the ninth and here's miguel
cabrera
and that will do it
so the royals are shut out last night
they shut out the tigers tonight
they have won seven of their last eight
with
scored twice salvador perez drove in
three